and then it needs to rain once every two weeks
for the crop to properly germinate.
After that, you need rain every three weeks
for the crop to form its leaves,
whereas at flowering, you need it to rain more frequently,
about once every 10 days for the crop to form its cob.
At the end of the season,
you actually don't want it to rain,
because rains then can damage the crop.
Devising such a cover is difficult,
but it turned out the real challenge
was selling insurance.
We set ourselves a modest target
of 500 farmers insured after our first season.
After a couple of months' intense marketing,
we had signed up the grand total
of 185 farmers.
I was disappointed and confounded.
Everybody kept telling me that farmers
wanted insurance,
but our prime customers simply weren't buying.
They were waiting to see what would happen,
didn't trust insurance companies,
or thought, "I've managed for so many years.
Why would I buy insurance now?"
Now many of you know microcredit,
the method of providing small loans to poor people
pioneered by Muhammad Yunus,
who won the Nobel Peace Prize
for his work with the Grameen Bank.
Turns out, selling microcredit
isn't the same as selling insurance.
For credit, a farmer needs to earn the trust of a bank,
and if it succeeds, the bank will advance him money.
That's an attractive proposition.
For insurance, the farmer needs to trust
the insurance company, and needs
to advance the insurance company money.
It's a very different value proposition.
And so the uptick of insurance has been slow,
with so far only 4.4 percent of Africans
taking up insurance in 2012,
and half of that number is in one country,
South Africa.
We tried for some years
selling insurance directly to farmers,
with very high marketing cost
and very limited success.
Then we realized that there were many organizations
working with farmers:
seed companies, microfinance institutions,
mobile phone companies,
government agencies.
They were all providing loans to farmers,
and often, just before they'd finalize the loan,
the farmer would say,
"But what if it doesn't rain?
How do you expect me to repay my loan?"
Many of these organizations
were taking on the risk themselves,
simply hoping that that year,
the worst wouldn't happen.
Most of the organizations, however,
were limiting their growth in agriculture.
They couldn't take on this kind of risk.
These organizations became our customers,
and when combining credit and insurance,
interesting things can happen.
Let me tell you one more story.
At the start of February 2012 in western Kenya,
the rains started, and they started early,
and when rains start early, farmers are encouraged,
because it usually means that the season is going to be good.
So they took out loans and planted.
For the next three weeks,
there wasn't a single drop of rain,
and the crops that had germinated so well
shriveled and died.
We'd insured the loans of a microfinance institution
that had provided those loans
to about 6,000 farmers in that area,
and we called them up and said,
"Look, we know about the drought.
We've got you.
We'll give you 200,000 Euros at the end of the season."
They said, "Wow, that's great,
but that'll be late.
Could you give us the money now?
Then these farmers can still replant
and can get a harvest this season."
So we convinced our insurance partners,
and later that April, these farmers replanted.
We took the idea of replanting to a seed company
and convinced them to price the cost of insurance
into every bag of seed,
and in every bag, we packed a card
that had a number on it,
and when the farmers would open the card,
they'd text in that number,
and that number would actually help us
to locate the farmer
and allocate them to a satellite pixel.
A satellite would then measure the rainfall
for the next three weeks,
and if it didn't rain,
we'd replace their seed.
One of the first —
(Applause) — Hold on, I'm not there!
One of the first beneficiaries of this replanting guarantee
was Bosco Mwinyi.
We visited his farm later that August,
and I wish I could show you the smile on his face
when he showed us his harvest,
because it warmed my heart
and it made me realize why selling insurance
can be a good thing.
But you know, he insisted
that we get his whole harvest in the picture,
so we had to zoom out a lot.
Insurance secured his harvest that season,
and I believe that today,
we have all the tools to enable African farmers
to take control of their own destiny.
No more years of the cup.
Instead, I am looking forward to, at least somehow,
the year of the insurance,
or the year of the great harvest.
Thank you.
(Applause)